- So Disney announced
that the character, Lefou,
in Beauty and the Beast is
gay (sighs and clucks tongue).
(upbeat music)
If I can't sit through a movie
with God or Jesus sitting by me,
then I don't got no business showing it.
Outside of the liberal media,
a lot of good folk are commending me
on my stance to ban this movie
so I thought I'd take this opportunity
to let people know about the
other films I've wanted to ban.
We'll start at the top,
obviously Harry Potter,
cannot show that film.
Witchcraft has no place in any school.
Moana, had to ban it.
Ocean ain't no person,
mountains ain't no lady.
Zootopia, also Disney.
Gazelles aren't that sexy,
animals shouldn't be depicted so sexy.
Jurassic Park.
The earth is only 3,000 years old.
All of those bones were
just planted by the devil.
Star Wars, ain't nothing in
the stars besides heaven.
Frozen, witches.
Banned it.
Lion King, again, Disney.
Teaching kids to run
away from their family,
hang out with a bunch
of gays in the woods,
have premarital sex, then come back
and you can be king?
How the Grinch Stole Christmas,
not one mention of Jesus
Christ in a Christmas movie.
I'm gettin' too fired up.
Toy Story, I had to ban that
one because of communism.
You can't be born into an
occupation you can't get out of,
I just can't support that.
Tried to show Moonlight,
people said it was important.
(laughs) That was a mistake.
Shrek Forever After, had to ban it.
They should have stopped after three.
It was a perfect trilogy, really.
Juno, I liked that
movie, she kept the baby,
that's the right thing to do.
Had to ban it because
they gave her a choice.
Pocahontas, demonizing humans.
Monsters, Inc. humanizing demons.
Banned.
Dog's Purpose, like I wanna show
a movie about reincarnation
and animals having souls.
No thank you, next!
Mad Max, presenting this idea
that all these fossil fuels
will lead to some sort
of desolate landscape.
Yeah, that's real, that's real.
Planet of the Apes, I
don't wanna get started
about this movie, but I'm gonna have to.
People think that humans
came from monkeys.
Look at a monkey and look at me.
Do you think I look like a monkey?
No, sir.
Finding Dory, you can
find another theater.
Good luck finding one.
Get Out.
No, sir.
Great Wall, now see I thought that one
was gonna be about the important wall,
but it turns out it's about
Matt Damon with a ponytail
save the Chinese from lizard people.
Good movie, I didn't band that one.
I like Matt Damon.